uh it's uh the last session
of a wonderful week
and uh i want to thank uh katie and
simon
for the organization absolutely
wonderful
for me it was very inspiring and
educational i have to say
so um let's uh continue with our first
speaker this afternoon sui tang
and
i'll let you read the title
yeah yeah please yeah thank you thank
you for your introduction so first of
all i would like to thank the organizers
for such a wonderful program and
especially for katie andersen mla for
organizing this workshop to bring us
together i really enjoy my stay here
it's my great pleasure to
speak in this workshop i'm going to talk
about learning interaction kernels
in stochastic systems of intaking
particles
and this research
basic
is
impartially motivated by
the
birds watching in the sky
and uh we also acknowledge the support
from nsf understand barbara and this
talk uh is based on a joint work with
failure and lamar majani from johns
hopkins university
okay so recently
the rapid advancement in data
information technology and the
computation
actually have inspired extensive
research effort
towards the data-driven discovery of
dynamic systems
and for example how to fit weather data
into a dynamic model to make numerical
predictions and how to model the motions
of robots and also relevant system
identification problem in control theory
and as well as how to understand
mechanism of infectious disease such as
copin 19.
so all these questions
involve extracting govern equations or
laws from data so in this way we can
have a interpretation about any dynamic
system and make predictions and
simulations
and you many of you may have seen this
example in the textbook of calculus like
this system consists of a single
pendulum and we are taught how to derive
the dominant equations for this
simple system however this is not the
case in in many practical scenarios
under the system line typically very
high dimensional and we only have very
limited physical knowledge and we have
complicated data so this actually
imposed greater challenges uh to start
to tackle this problem
and
recently there's a lot of effort from
applied and computational
math community as well as machine
learning on to propose different
approaches to tackle these problems um
and
the examples such as sandy algorithm
like using ideas from the sparse
regression and
also the approach inspired from deep
learning like physics informed neural
networks and pde net and in particular
the watch time matrix has been applied
to analyze the time series data in fact
u9 on tuesday she gave a very
interesting talk on how to use optimal
transport to learn chaotic dynamics from
data
and we also see a lot of workshops
coming out recently
trying to bring uh bridge the machine
learning physical science and dynamic
system together so we can expect a lot
of exciting work will come out
um okay in this talk actually i'm not
going to discuss the learning strategy
for arbitrary dynamic systems i'm going
to focus on the a special family of it
like called impacting particle
systems and they are very very common in
our daily life and here a few
examples
so if each example actually we see here
the moving objects as moving particles
and they impact and display
a variety of behaviors uh it is an
outstanding science problem that to find
the individual interaction rule that are
responsible for these collective
behaviors and this kind of problem has
attracted continuous attention maybe
dates back to the age of kepler and
newton and extensive research effort has
been made um and in this talk actually
i'm going to present a family of a first
order stochastic system of integrity
particles with pairwise interactions
that are have been like extensively
studied in the literature and trying to
describe the motions of this impacting
particles and here i want to be as
general as possible
and uh
and the suppose we have n agents x1 to
xn in rb they impact according to
this form of gamma equation since the
different term we may have an external
potential as well as the
pois integration governed by the kernel
ki prime and we also have a diffusion
term here sigma and modeling the random
effects
and there are remarkable remarkable
progress on quantitative analysis
quality
of analysis as well as a numerical
analysis on this type of government
equation as well as the mean federal
limit so it has wide applications in
modeling the opening dynamics particle
dynamics and swarming dynamics
and we also see the applications of this
type of equation in the previous two
workshops in this program like sampling
and optimization
um and in our workshop actually franca
and the uh tedo talk about their
application in
yesterday's talk and make a very nice
summary and here i'm very like lazy i
don't miss the relevant literature here
um so so far the majority of the work uh
in the majority of work these like terms
in these governing equations are
predetermined if we consider say we want
to apply these governing equations to
match the real-life data
and then this will inspire us to
consider the fundamental problem like
suppose like we have data generated from
the government equations what are the
data-driven methods that can allow us to
derive estimate of these
terms in the governing equation
oh yeah yeah yeah that's true uh
thank you for pointing out
yeah before because i write it as x i
prime and x i that's why i say it's r d
times r d but now i change to the minor
sign so yeah thank you for pointing out
that's a typo
okay so recently there's a lot of work
towards the data-driven discovery of
integrity particle systems
and here is a like
of course a non-exhaust exhaustive list
and i believe like people from a various
background has have made contributions
to this type of problem um and here i
may input the work in two categories and
the first one is a parameter estimation
i also call like parametric inference
problem and typically according to some
prior physical knowledge and knowledge
governing equations reduced to learning
some unknown parameters like vectors
in the system
and then given the data and people will
construct objective function involving
uh solving this pde constraint or sd
constraint optimization problem to get
estimators of these uh uh i know unknown
parameters and for example like the
diffusion estimation like here the
people consider how to infer the
diffusion constant from a partial
observation of a large scale
particle system and there's a lot of
reasonable work on gps measure in both
linear system and nonlinear system with
application for example to the cloud
dynamics and here i want to mention some
work in statistics like people do
exploratory data analysis they really
use the stochastic impact particle
system to model the animal's warming
behavior as well as doing the sports
data analysis and for example david
brenninger i mentioned him here because
he is the decision working here at uc
berkeley
and um in the past a few years all group
has worked on the non-parametric
inference and also solved this problem
in from the perspective of inverse
problem
so compared to this previous work we
don't assume any parametrical form of
the unknown terms in this governing
equations and the majority of work has
been done in the deterministic setting
and as
i mentioned in in her talk like for the
inverse problem we have to consider when
the data have noise and the first
situation is the data has measurement
noise and the second situation is that
the system has intrinsic noise and of
course the photo situation is that they
have both uh intrinsic and extrinsic
noise um so this actually motivated us
to extend our work to first consider the
situation we have the intrinsic noise so
we consider this a problem in the
stochastic setting and in general this
problem could be very difficult just as
like what we did before like for the
determined setting our starting point to
investigate this problem uh starting
with the pairwise radio interaction
radio interactions
so here we make a very specific
assumption
about this interaction form so you have
a fee acting on the pairwise thesis and
the times the pairwise difference in
position
and in the compiler form actually uh we
can represent this f only depends on v
and it is the gradient of an energy
function only dependent on pairwise
distance and this phi is relevant
to the derivative of the energy function
and um
and in this kind of system and the
dimension is still dm but we have a very
simple interaction rule like the
dimension is only one and nevertheless
um this kind of system and its variance
can still generate a variety of
collective behaviors and so widely used
so i have say numerical examples of this
kind of systems in many speakers talks
like kt uh jose and niwon's talk um and
uh i believe yongshin will talk about
the application of integrity particle
system in control theory if he's going
to show any numeric example i just make
a prediction he may show some example uh
involve the radio interactions i'm not
sure i'm correct let us see
okay so
now i'm ready to
make the official statement a problem
statement so here as i mentioned we
don't want to do the parametric seating
so what we know here the prior knowledge
is that this fee
like here for example is say one
function like has a bounded derivative
and
i mean if we know this and then we know
this as the is where post has unique
strong solutions and also we assume
sigma is known
and the training data here
consists of the um the observations of
this xt at some time window let's say
zero to capital t and we can choose
uniform time instance or non-uniform
time instance and we also consider the
case that we may have trajectory data on
collected from different replicas of the
system so we are observing the system at
uh um
starting with different initial
conditions so here is a visualization of
of the data regime uh so now suppose
like we observe this kind of data can we
actually construct some method that give
out as major v hat that is close to fee
and because we know phase
relevant to the energy function so they
give us the physical insights and also
we would like to use feedhead to make
meaningful predictions and simulations
on larger time interval so these are the
goals we want to achieve and
this problem setting is exactly the
stochastic extension of our previous
work for determining system
um
okay so
um in fact this kind of learning problem
belongs to a spatial instance of the
statistic inference for sdes so this is
a very well established area in
mathematical statistics and
and and
we first read the literature like what
the work people have done there so we
found out actually the non-parametric
drift estimation in high dimension sde
is very challenging both theoretically
and numerically
and uh here are supposed to have a drive
function b v x t in the general form uh
and then we want to invert it from the
trajectory data the majority work has
been done when the sde is organic and
considered a single trajectory case
um as long as the dementia is bigger
than two then
then the cells become very challenging
and we don't have fun many like
literature in this direction we know
that for example dalian and the wrist
give the first convergence rate of this
uh s majors back to 2007 using the
current type estimators and the known
statistical automatic results has been
established okay on the very recent
paper by nikon array and they show this
kind of rate is optimal in the l two
notes and you can see that even here um
this d n is um is going to be cursed by
the dimensionality the end so that's
kind of
no if this b is very high dimensional
you need a lot of data actually to to to
to recover uh this b up to a certain
accuracy
and compared to the organic case really
of very few work in the nile garden case
and unfortunately our
interactive particle system is never
ergotic
and um so we consider in this
non-guardian case with multiple
chargeable data we also find a
reasonable work by comic and a general
catalog uh trying to tackle this problem
in the 1d still they obtain some
convergence rate and no optimality
result has been achieved and all work
actually fitting in this city
we have a like uh in general like uh uh
the dimension is dm not equal to one but
we have a simple interaction rule
dimension of v equal to one and we are
trying to say what's what i mean what's
the uh available learning strategy for
for for our case so i was told that
actually when we try to tackle this
problem the first approach i should try
is the maximum likelihood estimation we
should understand what when in the works
when it didn't if it didn't think about
the variance um so
uh so what is the mathematical
foundation for this uh maximum
likelihood estimation is a cassandra
theorem because this theorem has been
mentioned many times in this
workshop uh so here i give a very simple
simplified version about it um
so suppose we have a like uh ic like
this and let's say p sigma is the
problem measure induced by the true
solution driven by b and the b sigma is
uh the the law of the respective
giftedness process namely b 0 and as not
as the noise is non-degenerate and also
b fulfill some conditions and then the
sun ethereum actually tell us a way of
computing the likelihood ratio
between the uh of the measure
generated by the true sd and the with
the with respect to winner measure so
how to understand the quantity is like
we can interpret as the probability of
saying trajectory if the underlying
system is driven by
b
and based on on this cassandra theorem
uh of course for first of the approach i
want to try is that in the continuous
time setting um so here suppose we
collect data from different applicants
and here is the error function for the
path for the m pass x0 t2m
let's say we consider any potential
candidate function like put bar fee here
which i highlighted in the blue column
so this
uh i calculate the negative log
likelihood uh
of
of this error functional so this means
this is actually represent the
probability of seeing the trajectory if
this system is driven by the valve v
now we are given like m like data
collected from m independent
trajectories so we take the sum so this
actually this quantity actually is a
negative log likelihood of uh the of um
saying the m trajectories if the
the system is um driven by rafi now we
want to maximize the probability of
saying the trajectories which is
equivalent to minimize the negative log
likelihood here so that's why we say
this is a maximum likelihood estimators
and given this error function you see
this is quadratic and very if it's a
very efficient to compute and we choose
a very simple hypothesis space uh trying
to minimize and in this way we get an
estimator v hat and for example we use
piecewise polynomials like splines and
wavelets and to do this and for of
course this is a continuous time but in
practice we only have discrete time so
how to do that
okay so here we consider like um we use
the oil marijuana to give approximate
likelihood of course some higher order
methods may be used and we use this
because it's simple it's really simple
and in the preserve uh the structure of
this error function is still quadratic
and we can solve it
using the least square
okay so this story and also
we solve this minimization and by
forming the normal equation in a
parallel fashion and then we use the
pseudo-inverse to find out the
coefficient and here is the computation
cost uh involving how to form the normal
equation and
how to solve this normal equation
okay so how does the work and we test
this approach um several protective
systems and this is maybe one of the
most simple example
um and so this the dimension is pain and
we
they have 10 opinions in the system and
we observe the system and multiple times
and if here this m equal to 32 and we
have the noise sigma equals 0.1
and here this blue curve this black
curve is true and the blue curve is
estimator you can see that it really
fits pretty good
and
if we
actually uh increase the data size and
of course we achieve better performance
and also we test like the case when we
increase the noise level and still we're
doing pretty good job we can actually
identify these opinion interactions uh
heterophysics and uh we also test their
ability in predicting the trajectories
so you can see that we take a uh like
measurements from a very tiny interval 0
to 0.5 and i'll make predictions on 0 to
50 and both on the training data and
make the prediction as well as on the
new datasets and to test the genetic
generalization ability and all of them
doing a very good job
um okay so now we just test like uh
several numeric examples we really want
to have a fundamental understanding to
say when this mle approach worked when
didn't okay so how to tackle this uh
problem um so in the classical
literature people concerned about the s
material of this f fit like treated as a
function b i mentioned in the previous
slides and here we are interested in
ionizing how the estimator of v
denoted by by this symbol so we are more
like in the inverse problem setting
because the v is a latent function
hidden in this high dimensional field
and of course there are several
asymptotic regime we consider we could
consider and here we'll consider mtl fix
and the m goes to infinity and to tackle
this problem we need to find a matrix to
access the estimation error
and um and also for the inverse problem
side a fundamental problem is trying to
address the identifiability problem you
might have like infamous data can we
actually uniquely determine on this feed
from a data otherwise the the s major
learn from finance data have very
limited value as a scientifical and
predict prediction tools
and also we're concerned about rate of
convergence which is a fundamental study
in the statistics inference like this
kind of question is to address okay if
we have some uh we want to achieve some
estimation error up to certain accuracy
epsilon how much m and hm should be such
that we can achieve this task
and
lastly we want to also do some analysis
on the trajectory predictions so these
are the fundamental questions i want to
address
okay so
the first step for the evaluation matrix
we we actually extend our work in the
deterministic case we introduce a
problem measure on the pairwise distance
and here you can see this dirac defined
on the pairwise distance between the
agents at time t and then we take the
integral and we take the average
we have n just two pairs and we take
average over the t because we observe
the dynamics at from zero to capital t
and then from this problem measure uh we
actually introduced a mean squared error
which i defined here and we introduced
an additional factor r here this is to
incorporate the structure of government
equations uh it looks like very abstract
but here if i think carefully i think
this is really a lateral matrix to
consider in our regime
because according to the structure of
equation this field
this energy function depends on pairwise
distance so only
we are only able to learn this
free at the regions explored by this
pairwise distance and here in this
figure i use the orange
histogram to represent the density of
this roti
and
you can see that in a very short time
due to the randomness of initial
condition and it can actually explore a
pretty large region so we are able to
learn this field on this region and also
you can see from here we don't know that
good at locations near zero so you can
see back to here if i equal zero we have
very little
weights if we consider our push row t
and so that's how we lose the
information here and of course if uh
this one here is the density axis and in
this case we have zero 3.5 if we
actually
have a larger noise you can see that
this noise actually smooths out on this
density plot so in the
in the case of nitrogenous
we have
larger fluctuations at the dislocations
this also may uh saying that this weight
is never is much is fewer than the
previous one this also gives some
explanation
and another reason is that um
this error matrix also promotes the
trajectory predictions um suppose we
have found a s major v hat minus v in
this estimation error here is zero and
then we almost can this freehand v can
generate the
the same trajectories up to time t
almost surely
so um so that's why i actually want to
promote
use this evaluation matrix um
so also for the nfl bnt and we propose
some cohesivity condition and for any
hypothesis space we used uh here we need
this kind of inequality to hold so you
can see here this is some energy of this
interaction force field we hope that is
bounded below by a positive constant
times this l2 arrow r2 measure of l2
norm of this v
here so why is that here is that so this
intuition coming from that in the
when the data is infinite and we have
expectation of the error functional and
this cohesive condition actually yields
the following quantity you can see
clearly here
um if we find some buffy which minimizes
error functional and that we should
achieve the same value with feed thing
then this roughly equal to feet in that
l2 space and
this inequality of course holds more
journey on any like hypothetical space
uh so the indication is that smaller the
risk of functional and close the
estimation is to the truth so
and af if we do uh if we assume uh this
cohesive constant is right which viewed
as a stability constant of the inverse
problem uh in the infinite dimensional
setting then we are able to prove the
convergence of estimators for the
continuous time observation so here uh
assume we have we use any kind of
sequence of linear spaces uh here we'll
we'll assume it's c one one so the first
derivative on snipchies continues
and assume that this ln has a linear
growth on this uh hyperparameter m
and uh assume like the approximation
power given by ln is measured by n to
the negative s
and here we'll put additional
constraints on this um hypothetical
space we use we assume that it satisfies
the markov of both standing quality so
this type of equality are often used in
the inverse approximate theory
literature
and then
um and this setting if we will have like
data collecting from ama trajectories we
can select this n sterilize this number
so it depends on the number of data we
have as well as the regularity then the
rate of convergence is 2s over 2x plus
1.
so it's equivalent to a one
one one dimensional non-parametrical
regression rate established statistics
so here i once said a three is not too
restrictive actually it has been proved
in approximation theory that it holds
for many like function space like
polynomials trigonometry
trigonometric polynomials uh spline
space wavelets and the more recently
rational functions and for example if we
know this v is uh like in this space ck
alpha so this
is uh the case derivative is a holder
continuous of order alpha and then we
can use those polynomial splines of
degree s minus one with uniform notes
and then we obtain the min max reading m
the same as the uh in the parametric
uh setting
and
oops
sorry so and the main gradients i'll
prove here we use the boston quantity of
n bond in the random variables involving
the stochastic integral and and based on
interformular and we we actually
leveraged the novel argument making this
paper uh in the non-parametrical
regression to our city and this markov
both standing quantity actually helps um
to obtain the uniform bound in the
covering argument to control the
variance error
okay so
our results are supported by numerical
findings so i only have a few minutes
left so um actually this is only in the
baby step for i see that has all many
open open problems and here we only show
that this um mle works well when this
delta is small and we can do parallel
implementation and we can have strong
consistent consistency and we'll have
one d max rate of convergence
and uh in in the if this delta t is very
uh is sufficiently not one in trouble so
in the paper will show that actually
this estimation error is going to be
bounded above by square root of delta t
com um and you can see this is a plot
and from the blue and pink we have
larger nodule the other t you can see it
will flatten the curve really the method
you know work when delta t is pretty
much so that's why like for the future
work we say how i mean what's the
learning approach when delta you speak
known for increased data as well as for
the non other isotopic regime like n
goes infinity and what if like we both
have m and t goes to infinity and here
we show very promising like plots like
uh showing the desired read here
and also um what about learning from a
gradient data not only from the random
major as
discussed in united's talk and multiple
interaction kernels and the second order
system so there are many open questions
and so you are interested in this kind
of problem please let me know thank you
for your attention
[Applause]
thank you sir very much uh any questions
yes go ahead
thank you that was great um i have a
question so um
what about the problem when you have to
learn the the diffusion part
the volatility let's say because here
you use your sanoffs and this works
great when you when the the dvt term is
kind of like the same
but do you have any ideas what to do in
case you also want to learn what is in
front of the dbt
oh i think that's a great question so
here uh um for this diffusion estimation
part i read the literature i found like
the people typically use the quadratic
variation techniques to tackle it and
assume like we need to have like full
observation of this data
and
um and so far the only work that i i
found that
actually deal with the partial
observation where any like variance is
uh is actually listed here and for
general i think this problem could be
very difficult i i don't know how to do
it i i found a very various gas meter
region here so this is the only paper i
found out for estimated constant
diffusion
if you have more difficult like
diffusion like the color noise i believe
a more difficult like matter has to be
proposed
yeah
exchange
very nice thought
uh i have a question regarding the
economy uh how to say that egotisticity
so
you're saying there's a distinguished
there's a difference between them yes
exactly economical one is easier
[Music]
exactly so that's a very good point uh
actually this system i consider here is
level orthotic but you know just in
terms of learning this fee we don't need
this whole system to organic we just
need to consider a relative position
systems yes uh it's organic like
golgotha in the pairwise distance that
may be fair enough for our learning
purpose so we observe that in our
numerical experiments that we are trying
to explore like if we change the
coordinates to the relative position
system that system could be organic and
we can learn this thing very well so
that's a very good
observation yeah okay thanks
quick question if
otherwise we can take it offline
okay i think
let's think i'll speak here one more
time
[Applause]